oh hi Christina hi there hi well
congratulations on your first Disney
Plus TV series thank you thanks our
first unscripted series - yeah we're
very excited
why was now the right time for the
Muppets to get into the streaming
business and to try something unscripted
well I think you know people but that's
why we called it Muppets now because
people can watch watch it when they want
to watch it you know if you want to
watch it right now you can watch it and
if you want to watch it
mmm now then you couldn't watch it then
so I think it's um you know and it's
it's all about Muppets doing what we do
best you know just uh silliness and
chaos whether the channel should get the
Muppets together and to keep them on
track to shoot the series and did any of
them not pull their weight that you had
to sort of get into shape up a bit
well you know we have a little thing
called schedules and nobody seems to
know there are schedules so I'm kind of
getting getting segments in at the last
second and trying to upload them and get
them out the door but you know we're all
everyone wants them to be great so we're
all working to the to the bitter end to
get them done and you know we're dealing
with um you know interesting
personalities I would say so uh you know
it's a challenge but it's fun along with
being responsible for uploading
everything you also run a game show with
Pepe yes one of the biggest challenges
of working with Pepe who clearly drives
you a little bit crazy yes yeah the big
challenge is the host of the show Pepe
who doesn't seem to know that when you
get the network approval on something
you have to just go with it you can't
change it last second so he's he's kind
of a freewheeling guy so uh you never
know what's gonna happen
keeps it interesting and bit stressful
yeah
would you say the the tips and tricks
are with working with someone like Miss
Piggy um lots of nodding nodding she
likes nodding
she likes um agreeing when you he when
she likes to hear the word yes a lot she
doesn't like to hear the word no very
much um and just sort of stay out of her
way yeah well now that you've done this
show for Disney Plus what what's the
next step in your career do you have a
dream project that you'd like to do oh
well you know I I we have some things in
development that I can't bring up right
now but personally yeah you know I'm I'm
kind of like in this sort of producer
role and sort of you know trying to
wrangle all these guys Kermit is
definitely the glue of the Muppets I
would say but I'm kind of like the butt
chewed up piece of bubblegum how are you
working my way through it at the same
time to have to work with Joe from legal
because that's a whole other laughs um
yeah he's sort of a new addition to the
Muppets uh yeah chosen Joe's a lot to
process let's let's say we've never had
to deal with anybody like that before so
it's been interesting he he secretly
wants to be in show business like he
really is a he wants to be like a
comedian he's not funny he needs to just
give up on the jokes well thank you
scooter I appreciate you talking to me I
love the show and thank you so much
thanks Christina